Let's roll the cameras.
Another game.     And black
against
1396.
OK,
so obviously we play the Sicilian
and we are still
at the stage when a lot of
players
play either anti Sicilians or
they play, you know, offbeat Sicilians such
as Knight F Three and Bishop C Four, like I
as I call it, the Italian
against the Sicilian. Although I think the
official name is the Bowler Attack. Here
we're facing Knight B one Two, C Three,
which is the   jumping, uh,   off point
to a variety of different
anti Sicilians. You might recognize the
Grand Prix Attack, which is the
move F Four on move three.
There is also the closed Sicilian which is
the Kingside bishop Ian Keto on the
next move. And of course, Knight
C Three does not necessarily preclude the
possibility that white goes back
into the open
Sicilian against virtually any of black's
moves. White responds in many
cases with Nike G One to F Three and then
plays D Four and then gets back
into an open Sicilian. So because
we are accelerated dragon players
in this speed run, it makes
perfect sense for us to
uh, roll out
and corresponding setup as
we've done before. And that set
up, of course, starts with the move night C
Six. Now, I'll
talk a little bit after the game, and I've
done this before about which move
you should play based
on    what
variation of the open Sicilian you play.
If you're a night orph player, you actually
don't want to go night C Six here. This is a
pretty well known idea because white can
what's called move order you into
a Sicilian that you don't
play    by flipping back into an
open Sicilian, if that makes sense. And of
course, in the night or if the knight
doesn't come out to C Six. So I'll expand
on that a little bit. Bishop E Five is
the third major
antisicilian variation. I don't think this
has a name.    Um, but
this line has been around for, for
decades now and it's a, it's
a pretty, it's like a faceless anti
Sicilian. It can be a very dangerous line if
black is not pretty
familiar with uh, the theory.
Black can get a bad position
positionally. And tactically   it,
it resembles a rosalimo, but of
course it's inferior to
Aurosalimo in, uh, the Rosalimo. There is a
knight on F three. And the function that
that knight fulfills is of course, it
protects the D four square.
So the principled move here and the move
that we are going to play and this is also
the response to Bishop G Five and the
trampowski, right? It's a pretty common
general type of move across
many openings. And that is, of course,
knight C six to D four. And
yes, we're moving the same piece more than
once, true. But in this
case, it's pretty clear that this knight is
a pretty monster piece. And we're also
pressuring the Bishop. So the main line here
for White is bishop B five to C four. Knight
F three is a sideline.
And I'll make an honest confession
straight away. This is not a sideline that I
remember the theory of very
well. So uh, we're just going to have to
make some stuff up here and that's kind of
going to be fun. Now,
the first move I think is quite obvious.
The reason we play 94 is
to eliminate the bishop on B five.
This move doesn't make much sense.
It just allows White to bring their
queen out and then we're not developed at
all so we might as
well give this night up for the
bishop. So we take the bishop and
now the vast majority of people and
this might be the move we play as well,
I think would instinctively play a six here,
right? A six of course is   a uh,
natural human instinct and it pushes the
knight back to C three. But I would
push back on the idea that a six is
necessarily forced, right? And it's, it's
worthwhile to explore these instincts you
often have because they can actually be
wrong the night on B five. It's not
all that dangerous as
a standalone piece, right? So we actually
could play a move   such as
D six or we could play even a move such as
knight G Eight to F Ah Six. Trying to
exploit the fact that the pawn on E four
is temporarily undefended and Knight F Ah
Six is quite an interesting move here as far
as I vaguely remember.
Um, so let me take a
moment here to think about what we want. To
play. A six is the, is the natural move and
then we can transpose into a bit of a
Nidorf setup by playing
a six and then D six.
We actually could get into like a souped up
Nidorf if White ends up playing D Four,
which I think he very well might, and
because I am a Nidorf player
myself,   this is something
people might not know. I played
the Nidorf Sicilian from the time that
I was about one six
1700 to the time that I was a uh,
2500 GM. So I played the nitor for many,
many years and that is the setup I feel
most comfortable with. And so for that
reason we are going to play a six,
chase the night away. And of
course after the game we will explore the
theory, we'll do some research and we will
figure out the best setup against bishop B
five. And now,     uh,
we're going to roll out the pawn and put it
on D six. And as we predicted, White
plays D four and we
get uh it's wrong to call
this an open Sicilian. This is still an
anti Sicilian because White
lacks the lightskirt Bishop. So
fundamentally the position is quite
different from uh, any nidorph
that we could get. And here we don't have
much of a choice. We don't want to allow
White to take on C Five and
favorably trade queens, drawing our king out
of its shell. So, of course we want to play
CD. And our opponent clearly going
down a theoretical line. I think we're
still stuck in theory. Now,
I could talk about this position for
ages, but in the interest of
time, I'm going to
hit on the important points.
There are going to be a couple of moves in
the next few moves, which I think the
people watching you might not fully
understand them, you might have objections
to them. And I promise that I'll expand more
after the game, but I want to keep some time
on my clock. This seems to be a dangerous
opponent. So what
is black's fundamental issue in
this position? We have the bishop pair,
which is great. Our pawn structure is very
healthy. The issue is that we lack
development. Right. We are seriously behind
a development, and that's always a dangerous
moment. Right. We don't have a single piece
developed, so you might say, okay, well,
let's get started. Let's go night F six,
right? The issue with night F six is
that white can actually strike in the center
with E five. Now what happens in that
variation? Well, after e five, we play D,
takes E five   white traits
queens, and then takes back on e five
with the knight attacking the F seven pawn.
And even though the queens are off the
board, it doesn't mean that White's
initiative suddenly subsides. If
you visualize that position, you'll see that
it's quite unpleasant for black. We have to
move the king back to E eight, and then
white gets the bishop out. And that
just seems like a pretty unpleasant
position. So we need to do something
about the possibility of White playing E
five. And yes, this
something involves a serious positional
concession, but I vote we make a positional
concession rather than get
crushed in some endgame where we're not
developed developing any pieces. What am I
talking? Well, definitely not f six. That is
way too big of a concession. Way too big
of a concession. Let's beat them to it. And
this is a pretty typical move
in certain
Nydorflike positions. And I'll
introduce a, uh, couple of other examples to
you. Queen before. Something tells me at
this point, either this is ridiculous level
of preparation, or our opponent is,
uh, just BSing. Something tells me he's
not BSing. Queen before actually looks like
a great move. This is a very high level
move. So, yeah, I'm
getting out theoret,
but that's okay. We're going to figure it
out. So you might see the move D
five and assume that it's
good for black, but we're not ready
to play D five. Right.
We would be biting
off way more than we can show. After
D five,    um, the queen will
drop back to B three, and then our e
five pawn is going to be hanging. I actually
don't even want to calculate that line. I
think we can do without D Five,   so we
lack development. We have also
created a major weakness on the D
Five square. So we've got a lot of problems
to solve here.
And the issue
with the move knight, uh, F six, is that
White brings the bishop out to G five. And
this is a classic positional idea. I call
this the Smith Slove idea, and I'll show you
the stem game after we finish.   Basically,
uh,   it's very simple to understand.
White takes the night away and
then sticks his own knight on D
five. And that's the last thing we want. We
want to be able to contest the
D Five square with our
knight. So, unfortunately, this
is not a move I really want to play, but I
think we have to play it. Starting with
bishop p seven puts a bandaid over the
problem. But after bishop e seven night
F six, again, white is going to play bishop
G five. I think we have to eliminate
White's control over the G five square
and play another pawn move. I
know
we're testing the limits of the strategy,
but our structure is still
very fundamentally sound, right?
Everything is defending each other. Yes, we
have a weakness on D five, but I don't
feel like we're getting checkmated here.
Concretely, I feel like we're finally
ready to bring our pieces out. And once we
do, we've got a lot of hidden assets in this
position, which can start coming out if
our opponent doesn't manage to continue the
initiative. And,    uh,
conducting the initiative is one of the
hardest skills in chess, and it's a skill
that many GMs don't aren't perfect
at, uh, bishop E three. So our opponent
develops the bishop, and
finally we can start developing
our own piece. So, without a second thought,
we play the move night F six.
You might notice that White has bishop to B
six here, which our opponent might play. But
this is not, I think, such a scary move. We
bring our queen up to D seven, and that's a
little bit awkward because it blocks the
development of the LightSquared bishop. But
the queen can park itself on C
six later to make space for the bishop. So
bishop be six played.
We can also play queen E seven, but that's
actually far more awkward. What is
our priority here? Well, our priority, as
you should understand,    is to
develop   your, um
actually, wait. There's a
crazy idea here for White.
Let me think about
this for a second.
Wow. I'm
speechless.   There's a crazy
idea that's making me speechless,
and it's actually
working. Um, so this is in
response to queen D seven.
The crazy idea is rook D
one. And if we play queen C
six there, we're walking into knight F
three, takes E five,
de five, and then rook D
eight. Checkmate.
So we have to solve that problem.
This is beyond my pay grade. I'll be totally
honest.    Okay, well, we have
ways to solve that problem. Let's go. Queen
D seven. Anyway,
White can also castle Queenside, which is a
super high level move.
Okay, um
yeah, this
is not great. I'm getting outplayed here.
So what we have to do
is move the queen. We have to move the
queen because White is threatening knight
takes E five. But where do we move it?
Well, we have to move it on a square such
that the queen defends E
five. Does that make sense?  Uh,
otherwise, White will play night takes
E five and deliver checkmate on you. So the
only square that I see is actually E
six. It's not a great square because we're
still blocking our LightSquared. Bishop. But
as long as we manage to castle, I
feel like we'll be okay.   I am
very worried about the move Bishop to C
seven here.     Um, I feel
like that's what a GM would play,
and I think
that forces us
to get into a pawn down
endgame.   I mean,
it's not great, but it's
something. And I have to say this. Bishop B.
Five line. In my defense, the reason I don't
really know it that well is because I am a
Nidor flare. And for my whole life, I
have avoided this line
by playing D six in this position. In
retrospect, maybe we should have done that,
but I'm offering an official
Accelerated Dragon repertoire, and I will
have gaps in that repertoire
myself. So   I think
that's part of the fun. Right? We do
research, and I fill those gaps myself.
Okay,
um, bishop C seven
played.   Oh, I can't even wait. No,
I can't play d five.
Um, we have to play D
five because otherwise White takes on D
Six. So we have to try this
move by hooker, by Crook. Like,
we   have to attempt this
move.     Um, and
let's see how White responds in
this position.     I'm worried about
just knight takes D five.
Just Knight takes D five,
and
that's basically
resignable after Night takes D
five.    Yeah. In this
position, because I can't take the Queen.
It's mate.
Okay, that was
some bait for a stream snack. Okay.
Queen a five.
Yeah. I'm starting
to smell a rat.
Okay, let's go, D four.
Let's see how our opponent responds in this
position.
So d four. Now, this could
still be theory, and if it is, then I
stand corrected. Something tells me it's
not.
Okay,   there's nothing we can
do.   Let's
set everything aside. We've been in this
situation before in the speedrun, and I
haven't been happy with how I handled it. My
request to everyone in the chat is that we
basically treat this like a normal game. We
do our best, and if I
lose,   we'll check the
game. If I believe he's
cheating, I will let you know. But right
now, we have this game,
I can still try to play the best
moves and that would be in the best spirit
of what we're doing, the speedrun. Um, it
doesn't matter what if we're playing Magnus,
right?    It's completely lost for black
at this point, but White still needs to find
a couple of moves here    and
the move that I think White needs
to find   is knight
f three takes e five. The
problem     problem is that we
can't take the knight. That's the issue.
Um, and the reason we can't take the knight
is because of rook Dhek, king e seven and
queen c five with mate.
So as black here,
there's only one thing that we can do, and
that's try to castle kingside. So the
only move here is bishop to e seven. We're
going to have to give up both of our center
pawns and castle.
Yeah. This is the strongest opponent we've
not only have we ever faced in sooner, but
this is the strongest one I have ever faced,
period.   The last time I got crushed
like this was maybe when I was like,
1600.
Um, but let's see how our opponent handles
the ensuing complications. Let's give him
the benefit of the doubt and let's assume
that all of this was theory, that this is
some deep chestable preparation.
Um,
now comes the moment
when our opponent really has to demonstrate
some technique. The game is far from
over. The game is not over.
Um,   we can still
hold this. You've seen me survive crazier
positions,     so
we're going to give our opponent the benefit
of the doubt    and
I'm going to try to
outline how I try to
survive dead loss positions, which is
another important topic in the meantime. And
our opponent finally taking his time. That's
a good sign, that's a good sign.
So what's happening in
this position? Well,
I would have taken on D
four, as probably would
99% of people in the chat within like,
two or 3 seconds. Our
opponent is contemplating other
candidate moves. I assume
there is a crazy idea
that white has here. I won't quite
reveal it, but if it's played, I
will confirm that that was the idea.
So let's see what our opponent comes
up with here. He's now taken
quite a while. Queen a four,
check.     So
it's a check. Right. And we can do a bunch
of things here. I don't want to go king FA,
that's just way too ugly.
We can play bishop to d
seven,      but
then that allows Simplification.
We don't want Simplification because we're
down a bunch of ponds.
Probably    we should play them
with b five,   but
then white has knight takes b five,
a takes b five, and
the rook on a eight hangs at the end of the
line.   Right.
Unfortunately, after b five, knight
takes b five,
and then we can castle,
but then the knight comes around and takes
the pawn on d four, and our queen is
actually trapped there.    Our queen
is actually trapped in that position.
So I have an
idea,    but this is like
the flimsiest of possible
ideas. It's interesting though. We're going
to go B five.   We're going
to go B five.
Now first of all, it's not a given that our
opponent sees knight takes B five. All these
mini tactics   are not that easy
to spot for players in this rating
range. But thus far, our
opponent has shown quite an ability
to navigate the
complexity     at a
grand master level.
Um, and Knight takes V five is no exception.
My idea was bishop to D seven. I
actually think this is a very clever
concept, folks, so give this a
chance. Bishop d seven.
Okay. Now I thought I might win a
piece here. Queen Takes D. Seven. And the
knight is now hanging. We are threatening to
capture it with our queen.  Let's see what I
missed here.    Let's see what I
missed here. I mean, I'm sure it's winning
somehow, but the thing is,
we are threatening to take the night with
our queen      and
it's not so easy to defend the night. I
mean, white can play the move C four. But
then already we castle and white's pieces
get very loose.
Oh, I see, there's the move
knight B five. I think to C three,
which I'm sure our
opponent probably saw a mile away.
But listen, it leads to an end
game and endgame's, even
completely lost ones lead to long games.
Long games allow us to milk some clock
and perhaps we can embark
on      a
campaign of trying to milk white's clock
down. We've already gotten like four minutes
off of it, which against an
opponent of this caliber is quite the
achievement.   Let's see what our
opponent comes up with here.
And for those watching on YouTube
and kind of rolling their eyes and being
like, why am I not saying what's on
everybody's mind? Again, if you
haven't seen my previous speeds, I have a
very strict policy for games in which
players  play
suspiciously, where
I don't comment on their play as long
as the game is going. When the game
ends, I share my thoughts. But
first and foremost, we look at the game
carefully with an engine. We give everybody
the benefit of the doubt. Again,
always the thought experiment you should do
is like, what if you just played the best
game of your life? Uh, most of you have
played 99% accuracy
games.        How
would you feel if you were the
person who has just played a perfect game
and 3000 people are
shouting that you're a cheater, right? You
would not   want to be treated that
way.    And um, I really believe in
putting yourself in someone else's shoes.
With that said, I'm not going to let
people slide if it's obvious that they're
cheating. But we're first going to
investigate carefully with an engine. That's
how you have to do it.     Not trying
to virtue signal here. That's
truly what I believe in,
um, because there are
truly many instances where somebody has
preparation   or
you think that they're cheating, but then
you check with the engine and they're
actually not playing top computer moves.
That also happens, but you've gotten it in
your head that they're cheating.
So    it's super important,
I think, not to do this.
So our opponent
is thinking he's deep in the thought we're
actually making some progress on
milking the clock.  I
really think knight C three is the only
move. What's interesting is there's this
move, knight B five to D six. Check.
And what happens in that line?
96, check. We play bishop takes D
six,   and the queen on a
four is hanging.
So if we calculate that
line, 96, check. Bishop takes D
six. Queen takes queen,
king takes queen.
Bishop takes bishop, king takes bishop.
We're up a night, and in that
resulting position, there is a fork. E five.
Check. But that pawn is undefended. We can
just take it.    If White
had a pawn on F four, then this line
actually would have worked and liquidated
into a winning rook end game.
Probably,
uh, DK guy is asking, is, okay,
night C three found
by our opponent.
So we have no choice at this
point. So, first of all, we cannot take the
night because the pawn is pinned. Everybody
should see that   we have to trade queens
because the queens are in contact
and our queen is
pinned. So we have two ways of doing
this. We can try to castle,
but that makes no sense to me
because    that gives White an even
better version of the swinging endgame. So
we should at least take
and now we should make a
decision. There is, of course, knight takes
C four. But the reason knight takes C four
doesn't work   is because of
rook H to E one.
And the pressure down the E file
is way too powerful, I
think.   Yeah, it
is, actually. It's not as easy
as it may seem there to
finish me off. I
think the alternative is, again, to
castle. There's also the move rook
C eight here try to hit the bishop, but
the bishop can just drop back to E five.
That's actually even better square
than C seven. So that's
counterproductive. We're going to be
down three pawns if we castle. So knight
64 might be the practical attempt
against
how do I put this delicately?
Against another player. I might
play night 64, but in the interest of
prolonging the game, I'm going to
castle,   try to get our opponent to use
clock, which, unfortunately, he
has stopped doing.
Okay, um, well, let's bring the rook into
the game. Not much that we can do here other
than just sort of sort of sit around and
wait for White to convert his three extra
ponds. But
another note that I'll make as you're
watching this, is that if you are trying
to figure out if someone's cheating.
Don't resign out of
disgust. Actually try to play
real chess because you're going to, uh,
actually build up evidence. Okay, so if
he is cheating, then
a 50 move game is usually
a lot more compelling than a ten move game
where you just resign because you're
disgusted.    So play
real chess.  And
this is what I'm doing here. I'm bringing my
rooks into the game. I'm trying my best.
We're just down three puns. That's the
reason black is lost. Our, uh, pieces are
actually the best that they have been all
game long.
But    at this point, we're
waging two different battles. We're
obviously   trying to gauge our
opponents play. And I'm still
trying to save this endgame,
right? Because on the off chance that
white actually starts playing
in a semiflawed
manner,   we will have a
chance. Okay? So we've gotten White to
think again. We've gotten White to spend
half of his time. So maybe if we can make
another 23 moves, we'll have a shot.
Although something tells
me it's not really the case. Night C three.
Good move.
So what we want to avoid here with black are
trades, right? We want to keep as many
pieces on the board as possible for as long
as possible.    And in the
interest of avoiding trades, uh, we don't
want to go Bishop C five here because of
rook to D eight check.
So we basically just want to sit around and
wait. And for that reason, I'm going to
play King H seven.
Um,
so that when we move our bishop, rook D
eight is no longer going to be a check. It's
still probably going to force
a rook trade, and it's obviously still
winning. There's just not much that I can do
here. Common misconception.
Like, I'm a GM. People
think that it's impossible to bring
GMs down. They never die. But there are
certain positions where,   uh, you see
what I see. It's not like I see something
special here and I'm going to create
chances. Like, basically, black just needs
to sit around and wait and hope that
white makes a blunder, which
is   increasingly unlikely. Night
h five. Only move.    Okay, this
targets the bishop, so okay, rook D
seven.     Okay,
let's go bishop before   still
trying.
Um, I've drawn these types of positions in
blitz, that's for sure. But
as I've tried to explain
many times and I might do a video on this
actually, I've never done a video on
I've talked about this on stream a
lot. And that's the concept of, like,
how do I know when someone's cheating?
What   stands behind
my intuition that someone's not
playing honestly? And part of
it is this feeling I always refer to
that you're playing against a wall, right?
No matter what you come up with,
your opponent has the perfect
response available to it,
uh, in response to it. And it's just like
this total feeling of hopelessness that's
really hard to actually quantify. It's
just a feeling you get born of,
uh, a lot of experience. We're going to go
rookie eight here, try to take on G Three
and moon back at least one of the pawns.
And I'm definitely getting that
feeling very strongly in
this game from the very opening
moves, like from the very moment that our
opponent blitzed out that crazy preparation.
Rookie two. Yeah, I mean,
I'm going to try to
blockade with rookie six. Notice that I'm
trying to play super resiliently, not giving
our opponent an easy job. But of course,
White is totally winning because he's just
up three pawns. King d two, f four,
maybe even f four immediately. That's what I
would play. But that's that's a GM move, f
four, because you have to give up a pawn
and people don't like giving up
their extra pawns.   And
then just push F Five and E six
and White's   black's position is blown to
smithereens there.
Yeah. Uh, Anecdotal says best thing
I've heard someone say is a feeling of a
noose being tightened from all directions.
Exactly.     And this is the feeling I'm
getting. Right, look at this play on all
sides of the board. King me to chase the
rook away. Okay, I oblige. I
oblige.   We have to
move.   The last thing we want to do is
take the bishop unless we're absolutely
providing. So this was the idea. It was
to chase the rook away and now to play a
four. Just exquisite
technique.
Is White actually winning with
correctly?
Is white winning. Look at the
position.
He's up three ponds.
Okay, king G six,
let's try
we are trying to build a
blockade on this square,
and I think at this point,
I think F,
uh, four was maybe a mistake. And see,
this is the exact point I'm
trying to make here. There is a
chance that it's just that he prepped
really well   and he's
trying his best and he's actually playing
super well. So   we
just have to complete the game and take it
in stride before we make any
conclusions.  Now, king G
six is a really strong move, by the way, I
think, from our perspective,
because we're actually going to
plant the king on F five, and it's
not going to be that easy for White to
dislodge that king. We're going to go king F
five. Okay, white is down to six minutes.
We're actually
making some progress. I think if we can get
White down to like, two minutes, he might
maybe start panicking. I don't know. We'll
see.    But look at what
I'm trying to do. I'm putting my
king on F five. The reason this was
necessary is because if we didn't do
that, white would have just pushed F Five
and then pushed E six. And clearly that
is game over.
So if White can get our king off
of F Five, then the game ends.
If White can push F five. Virtually in
any version, it's over.
So we're just going to try to keep this king
here for dear life. There's also the
past Cpawn, but that pawn isn't really
going anywhere at the moment. So
amazingly okay, king B three.
King b three.
Okay,
well,    I don't
see exactly what this does.
Yeah, we can play G
five here and try to disrupt I don't know
about G five. I mean,   a lot of
these moves are basically equivalent.
Um,
well, rook F seven repeats moves that
leads to a draw. White
obviously does not want to draw.
Um,   okay,
I guess   we can double
on the C file to maybe
prevent the move. C four.
Just again, trying
to make this as difficult as
possible for our opponent to milk a lot of
clock.   He's down at five minutes.
So it's starting to get just a little bit
interesting here.   But it's
just 15 plus ten is so much time
that you can basically afford
to think as long as you want on every
move.       Uh,
if somebody put a knife to my throat right
now, I would say that
he    probably hasn't used the
engine in 100% of moves,
but has likely
done it in, like,
a    frequent, uh,   has done
it frequently this game. But we'll see.
Again, no need to speculate when we have the
engine. Let's continue defending
gracefully.
And already I think rook F seven
check is a sign
that our opponent might be struggling just a
bit. We've taken another minute off his
clock, by the way, and rook B six check is a
threat that forces the king
onto the corner file. So
wait a second.   Wait a
second. This actually     wait
a minute. That M definitely must be a
mistake by him.
Um,
wait, this has gotten interesting.
All of a sudden,
we can push his king to the side
and it's almost made,
um,
pause. Champ.
So do you guys see what I'm saying? You can
go rook B six or even rook B eight.
It's already almost a
draw. Wait, let me calculate. Let me
calculate for a second.
There's got to be something already. At this
point.   It's still lost. I'm
afraid     it's
still losing,    but not by
much.      It's
definitely still lost
because the king runs to a five. Okay, so
here's my idea.    All
right, well,
um,
let's start with the
check.  Let's start with the check.
Yeah,
if I can pull out a draw in this game, I'll
be the happiest person in the world.
So here's what I'm
calculating, folks.
I assume our opponent will go
king A four. It would be wild to play king A
three in this position, although anything is
possible. But king A three allows
an additional check on C three. I don't
know. Any person in the universe would play
king A three here.   Um, king A four
is logical.
Then what I was calculating is
rook to C four check, which I know all of
you see king A Five.    Rook
c four. King a five. Rook b five.
King takes a six. Rook a four. Checkmate.
Except it's not checkmate because the rook
um, on B five has lost its support. So
there's no way to ladder checkmate. I don't
see anything. We can try to move rook B
five now   to cut the
king off from the fifth rank.
But that's slow, right?
Rook B five is slow and white. We've
given white a tempo that he can
use to, uh, for example, play rook to E
four.   So I have an interesting
idea. Well, I don't want to play rook takes
E six because that relinquishes the net
that we have woven over White's King. I'm
going to make a move that you might find
confusing. I'm going to go knight h five to
f six.    But
the idea is very straightforward. We're
attacking. All of a sudden White's King is
under attack. This has gotten exciting.
And when you're attacking, the first rule
of attack is that you want to
bring    pieces into
the attack, into the game.
And that's what we're doing. We're
trying to bring the knight desperately,
quickly, as quickly as possible
into
the attack via D five. Now what
is it doing on D five, you may ask? Well,
it's it would be protecting
it would be
protecting
the rook. Okay. I don't
get this move. We can just take it,
I think, can't we?
What happens if I take
wait, let's
think.   I think we have to take
because if we don't, he just goes. Rooks e
seven
takes e seven.
Oh, and we're pinned.
Okay, um,
now we're going
to try. Let's see what he wants.
Yeah, you guys are right. I
didn't see seven from a distance.
We can try
rick b five. Maybe he
promotes
shark b five. Actually, this is
a super sexy move.
Rook B
five is a super sex no. Rookie six loses on
the spot. Rookie six,    he takes it
and goes. Rookie eight
or goes rook capsule. We don't
want to leave.
A lot of flares would promote here.
A lot of people would promote in
this position,
but obviously this guy is not a lot
of people.
No. Rookie five doesn't
work.      Rookie five,
I take it
that actually doesn't work. No. I have
managed to create mega complications
in this position,
but unfortunately the time control is
so vast that
he still has three minutes
left.
Whoa.
Bishop e one.
Okay,     stopping
the check on C three.
Cold blooded.
That is a dank
ass move right there. We got to go back
to e eight with our rook.
That is a standard
1300 level move.
Three to e one.
We've, uh,  gotten him down
two minutes, 40 seconds.
The game is still going.
Yeah. Bishop e one is a very
standard move for his level as is. Yeah.
Now c four.
Okay. Rook c five. It is
still in it. Still in it.
Give me at
least, uh, the problem is he starts
playing. He actually    is
playing quite fast.
And I guess he's just going to take
now.
But, um,
we'll see.
He whipped
me.
This doesn't look like
the best move
here. I check and go. King g six. No.
01:00 A.m.. I missing
king g six.
Still in it.
This does not look like
the best move, what he just did
there.
Okay, rookie
fate,    man. I'm impressed that
he's actually managed to play fast
and I guess c five.
Wow.
Wait,
let's try to defend from
behind with rookie two.
There's still a chance, I mean, there's
a chance that he plays a move quickly
and blunders. There's definitely
still a shot in this game.
A four.
All right. King b six. And it's
winning.
Wait, it's not over
yet.     It's not over
yet.     Yeah, fell for
it.      Not uh, only
is it not over yet, I might not even be
winning. So let's, uh, temper our
celebrations.
Let's temper our celebrations.
Yeah,
I think it's winning.
I think it's winning. But listen, this
pawn can hardly be stopped. So what do we do
here? What is black's best move
in this position? Let's go back to speedrun
mode. We've allowed ourselves a little too
much fun.
96. Yeah. 96. C seven. Knight
takes c seven.
Uh, I figured out the
win.   I figured out the
win.    And it
is   knight takes c
seven.
And
now     I
think we have a genius move.
No, we're winning. And
the genius move is a five. Very nice.
You guys got it? So there's two scenarios
here. Scenario one is where
we take on G two   and white takes on a
six.
Um, the problem in that scenario
is that white is going to promote the a
pawn. We're going to have to give the rook
up for the Apon. So we need to
win the Apon at all cost. How
do we win the a pawn? Well, we need to fix
it on a light square. So we play a
five here
and then we go rook to C four. So watch this
one. King up to B six.
Rook down to C four.
And the king cannot go up to B
five because that blunders the bishop on C
seven and we win.
Unbelievable. Now, again, there's a lot
to talk about here. A lot to talk
about.     I want to
repeat that I am not throwing out any
accusations.
Um, our opponent's play was
highly suspicious. We can all agree on that.
No matter where you stand on the whole
cheating question, we can
agree that the play was
odd. It's rare for me to be
outplayed by 1300. Not
impossible. Everything in chess is
possible, but it's rare. So we need
to check the game carefully with an engine.
There is also a chance that our opponent was
stream sniping because
a lot of the time I said a move, it
corresponded with it being played.
Um, let's push our pawn, maybe to a
four.   I think we should actually
start with King G five.
So
we need to operate purely based
on what the engine reveals.
Yeah, that
was a crazy game. And I have a
feeling that our opponent may have been
sniping because this was a crazy
coincidence. I literally said King B six as
a last ditch effort in
case our opponent is listening to the
stream.      Um,
let's go king H four. This is the easiest.
We just take around and win the pawns
bishop. Oh, I
blundered.    Wait,
actually, m I didn't blunder. Just I didn't
blunder. But actually I missed this move.
This is another nice move.   So we
go. Okay, actually, wait. This is an
instructive moment.
What we need to do is we need to eliminate
both of these pawns while keeping
at least one of our pawns alive. So the
way we do that is we play G Five.
We play G five
and then we don't play King
takes H three here.
No, because then we give up the G Five
pawn. We could end up losing the Apon and
that's a draw. So what's the move here?
It's not a four. Forget the apon. We don't
need the apon. That pond
can go    take a walk.
Yeah. So what we just need to
do rook A three, RC H two. We win
the HP on with a rook
so that the King can maintain contact
with the GPA. Then we take G four and
White's King is going to be way too far away
to stop the GPA. That's it. The game
is over.    Of course,
rook H Two was also similarly winning.
You don't even need the A pawn. This would
be completely winning without the A pawn.
That's it. And it will be completely
winning without the Apon.
Yeah. Table base draw. Yeah. We just
move the gang and promote
bang. Making sure that we're not blundering
the pond. Right. It took me a second
there. Just push, push, push,   push,
push, push.
And rook. H one
g one queen. And there
is a way to do this so that you intercept
the bishop. But it doesn't matter. It's just
going to make a queen.   What a game.
What a game. Uh,   this is going to be like
my most viewed speedrun video file,
which is kind of sad in a way,
but I kind of get it. Thank you, Jolia, for
the five subs. So we're going to
start in this case
by   running the game
through the engine briefly. And
this is not part of our analysis. We are
also going to analyze this game. But
we are going to begin with    just a
sort of overview
of our opponent's play. Now,
notice the accuracy might be completely
messed up because of the huge blunder. So I
wouldn't put too much stock here
in the accuracy.
That's sort of the
caveat.   I would not put
too much stock in the accuracy.
But nonetheless, we will start by
checking.    And
if we want to do this really properly, we
would do this on the stockfish engine, on
ChessBase, which is what we're going to do.
So I'm going to check the accuracy and
then we're actually going to do this
properly. Plugging in the game into Chess
base,     um,
where I have a much stronger
engine and an engine that
will go up to a certain depth.
So we're going to do it in a moment.
Let's, let, uh, the
machine run.
So as this loads, this is the speed
run. The emphasis is on
instructive value. So to those
who are watching this and are feeling a
little underwhelmed at my lack of
explanations, I do apologize for that. But
this is, uh, kind of hopefully an
extenuating circumstance. I will
explain a lot of stuff in
short order,   but
this is still part of your overall chess
improvement, right. Knowing how to deal with
these types of players, knowing the signs,
how to act in these
cases is, I think, very important.
Um,
okay, so 82.5, and
again, you can see that there was one
blunder and that blunder was king B,
mistakes.    And it also says, I
had zero mistakes, I have higher
accuracy. This makes no sense.
Uh, you can just a priori. This makes no
sense. You know that because white was
winning completely the entire
game. So the accuracy
and it's skewed because of the
blunder. White blunder to full
roak. So what we do now is we plug the game
into Chess base,   we turn
on stock fish and we quickly run through it,
just kind of checking to
see   how many top moves
there were.   This is not a
scientific method of investigation.
I am not claiming that it
is, but we're trying to give ourselves a
better sense. Okay.     All
right, this should do.
So let's examine
now, first of all, we need to
analyze this opening just independently of
everything. And I have a feeling
yeah, as far as I
remember.   So here
you can see on the, uh,
right hand side, well, you're not
actually seeing it, but stockfish at depth
46 says e six is
equalizing. So this is already a mistake.
Amazing. D six apparently is a
mistake.   And it is because
of this line. Queen D four, e five,
and now queen D four. Yeah.
So this is apparently well known.
Yeah. 43
games in the database. Wow. So this
is a known line. You see, we
have to give our opponent the benefit of the
doubt. H six, bishop e three, still games
in the database.   Night f
six, still games in the database. And we can
see Jocelyn played this, josbum had this in
a title Tuesday game. Queen D seven,
castles and Jospen played exactly like I
did. We're following the game.
Incredible.   We're, um,  following it.
Jocelyn's title Tuesday game. You can
actually see it a little bit, uh, in the top
when they say a five one game.
That's the Jospin title. Tuesday game.
And Jos actually
won, which is crazy. But
that's a moot point.
So it's already plus four.
Now we check. So
d five.   Yeah. So this next
move is incredibly suspicious. Queen a five,
I don't know.   Queen b three is
more human to me. So queen a
five is a top move.
Knight takes e five
is basically a top move. Now it's a top
move.   Should be
seven.     Queen a four,
check. So this move
was not fantastic,
but not bad.   So this does not
spoil anything. B five, night b
597 and 93. But
these are all forced moves.
These are all forced moves. M rook d four
is top.
Bishop d three was the second
move. Rook d one is top.
Knight c three is the second
move.    D
five
is slight
inaccuracy.
Slight inaccuracy. But still it's plus six.
So you cannot make any conclusions on the
basis no. Rook d seven is the second move.
Now      rook f
seven is the second move.
Okay? But rook d two is
obvious.     Rookie
two is the first move.
King b two
maintains the
advantage. Yeah. King b two is the second
move. Now
F, uh, four,
maybe not the most
accurate, but still
rook b seven is
good.    So king b
three is a little bit
inaccurate.    Ding. V three is a little bit
inaccurate. And actually, g five was a move
here    rook f
seven. Okay. So this is
already      black is
going, white is going a little bit of
straight,   but f five is okay.
Uh, if I'm honest with you, this
was maybe the most suspicious moment. Like,
f five   and e seven
is incredible. And bishop e
1   second move is
bishop e one. Yeah.
Bishop, uh,
e one is an amazing move.
I mean, uh, it makes
sense.    And c
four is good.
Bishop g three is
also good move.
Yeah. Rook fate is not
perfect,     but this is
still completely winning. Oh, c
five is good.   A four
is good.   And it's completely
winning after rook c eight.
Yeah.
Um,   so what
conclusions can we draw from this
brief      run, uh,  through?
Well, first of all,
knowing that line, as you know,
1300 is
exceedingly rare. But we again,
it's not impossible. Maybe
he looked this up. Maybe this is his his
jam, right? His line.   It could
be another smurf. So there's an option
that this is a smurf and his real
strength. Uh, based on this game, I would
estimate at 24
2500ft A, but at
2400, would never, ever,
ever in a 15 minutes game blunder king b
six. So that's what doesn't add up. And
that's what tells me maybe he was stream
sniping because I deliberately said king b
six. I did this twice. The
first time, I think he didn't buy
it. The first time was when
in this position, I said,
knight takes d five is winning. It was a,
uh,  troll. Obviously,
the second time
it actually did work.
So
he's up to something, I'm pretty sure of
that.   But
my standard for these
videos is like, if he's watching this
video, I'm hoping that he
would find my perspective
to be reasonable.   Like, we looked over the
game.     This was an
incredibly well played game.
It's virtually unprecedented for
1300 to be able to play a game like
this.    Um, so
there's never any, like do I
have any cold, hard proof?
No.    Um,
but        this
is what I can say.
Okay.   But
nonetheless, there's no direct
accusations. We just looked over
the game, I expressed my suspicions and
that's, that   chess.com
always investigates fairly
and   I'm going to let, uh, them
do that.    Let's
analyze the game.
So we're actually going to analyze it in
chess space.   I actually like this
layout. The reason we're going to do that
is because this was an engine
heavy game and it's sensible
for us to use stockbridge. We're
going to deviate from
our golden rule, which is to never use
the engine explicitly in
analysis. But this game was so technical,
there was so much going on that I think it
just makes sense to focus on the opening
phase   and, um,  make sure that we
know how to play against Bishop B Five.
Remember that that is the goal of this
feeder and is to develop a fullopening
repertoire. So that's what we're going to
focus on.
Um,  so let's rewind back
to the start.
So night c three.
Now, it's important to realize
what I said
when this game was starting, which is that
if you are an accelerated Dragon player
and you want to go Night C Six.
If you're a Nidorf player, you want to go D
Six.   Right? Because if White
goes Night F Three and doubles back to the
open system, you want to be able to play a
Nidorf.   Now,
conversely, accelerated Dragon works the
same exact way, right? Night. C six. If
White now goes Night F Three, just go G
Six and you play and accelerated
and Anticillin is anything that's not
the open Sicilian.
Now if you're a Nitorf
flare and you suddenly face this line,
there's no way to get back into the
Nidorf. Now you can play the move E Five
here to keep
the nonopen Sicilian
flavor. But the latest verdict on
this line, which is a very popular line,
I don't like this for Black. I feel like
this is a very, very hard line to play,
although it's highly theoretical and it's,
and it, and it's been played by a ton of
GMs. So hopefully that makes sense. If you
are a a con Sicilian
player, then of course you should play E
Six, which is a great move, by the way. E
Six against the closed Sicilian is, I
think, maybe even the best line. But you
have to be ready to face Knight F Three, and
then you're basically move ordered either
into a con or a Taimanov.
So based on what you play,
you should play that appropriate move here.
We played knight T six, and we're
facing bishop B five. So ni T four
is the topical move. And after nine
F three, let's see what the
engine   can, um,
bring to the table here. So as
far as I remember,
I think the best line is actually
to play A six here. That's
what the engine seems to be giving thus far,
a six.   If bishop C
four, then we can actually play B
five.    And we're not
afraid of bishop D five. We just go? Rook
BA. So you have to be ready in this
line to play creatively
and to delay your development by a little
while. Okay,    why
is this good for black? Because we're going
to play E six with tempo on the next move.
And the bishop is just going to be stupid on
this diagonal. And if white takes
and drops the knight back.
And look at this move. Knight F
six,    knight takes D
four, iron. And this is simple.
We take on D five,
and then we go bishop B seven,
fianceroing, and winning the pawn
back    with
interest.    So if white goes D
six, then we just go E six and we pick
up the pawn like this. Obviously, we
don't take that looks
terrible. And if queen F three, we go E
six,   using tactics to win the
pond back.   If queen
H five,
then we go rook C eight. This
is really this is really pretty. And rook
C five, we win the pawn back like this.
Everything looks easy when you're
analyzing of the engine.
So you have to toe the line
a little bit in this line.
But nobody's going to go bishop C four.
People go bishop D three here. That is the
main move. This I remember. And now e
six. So you set up essentially a con set
up. But because this is not an open
facility, you shouldn't be afraid of playing
this.   If white takes and goes
92, this is a very important now I'm
starting to remember this analysis. In this
position,   you do not go
bishop C five because then the bishop is
not positioned very well.
You go d five.
You go d five. And how does this
work? Well, what happens if white plays
night, takes D four, black plays De
and wins one of the minor pieces.
You see that, right? So the human
move here, I think, is E five.
But now this pawn is
undefended. This pawn is undefended. Whoop.
Queen G five fork.   And
again, we're getting away
with making this many moves with non
minor pieces because look at how passively
white's developed. The bishop on C one
is blocked in. We're not afraid. Our fund,
our structures sound here   f ah
four. White can try, but we
just drop our queen back. And if white
pushes, we just go E five. And this is even
better for black.   Does this make
sense? I hope this is making sense. Like, I,
um, have all these moves, and so far, all of
these moves, to me, are, like, perfectly
sensible. It's just a lot of concrete stuff
you have to remember here. And if
ed, then Queen takes d five,
let's say White Castles. And at this
point, I think it makes sense to start
developing the engine likes bishop D seven,
bishop C six. I like the move knight f six
here. I think this is simple. And black
is a perfectly good position here. So this
is how you analyze with an engine. You don't
just press the space bar,
which gives you the next engine move. You
actually try to understand why each move is
played. So, for example, even here,   why
bishop D seven and not knight f six. Why is
the engine prefer this move? Right? Well,
what you do is you say, after night f six,
what is the move? Well, the move is C
three. Then you ask yourself, well, why
is the same move not good after the
engine's recommendation?   And
you say, ah, uh, well, black has this move,
bishop C six. Okay, well, why is
bishop c six so strong?
Well, it threatens checkmate. And why is
it bad for white to play f three? Now knight
f six, and the idea starts
to crystallize.  The idea
starts to crystallize. After knight takes D
four, you have bishop to C five. And here
you see the damage that white has done
himself by playing F three,   and
we're able to win the pawn back with
interest.     Compare
that long line
with knight F six and now C
three. We don't have the equivalent
idea. If we play bishop
D seven here in bishop C five, we can still
do that, but there is no pin
anymore. And actually, the
knights still can't move, but it's just not
quite as effective.  Okay, so
bishop D seven is actually the most accurate
move here. Fascinating.
Okay,
so that was an exploration of
knight 64. The main move,
as far as I remember, for White, is just a
castle. And here, I really like how the
computer handles this. It's suggesting to
just drop the night back to C six and say,
hey, your bishop on D three looks
really stupid. I don't want to have
anything to do with this. Knight C six is
what's been played against me when I played
this line with White.   And after
bishop E two,
we can go back to D four. I mean, this
is a repetition that could
happen,     um, because
if white takes here, the knight is nowhere
good to go. It doesn't have e two anymore.
And remember that in this
position,     uh, there is this
very typical maneuver where
you go 97 and then 96 in
order to protect this pawn. And
this pawn is a strength, right? It's
lording over the whole position.
So there is the possibility of repeating
moves. But there is also
the possibility,      um, in
this position, let's see if there are
alternatives to 94. Let's say you don't
want to repeat moves.   Wow. Look at the
second recommendation, G
five.     I actually
kind of like this move.   And
the idea should be obvious. You're
basically   going for the attack.
You're going for the day, you're preventing.
D is a
prophylactic move. That's all it is. That's
all it is. And it's an idea that exists
across a lot of different lines. It's been
very popular to play G Five in these types
of positions. Let me give you an
example. There is a line in the
Bishop B five. Czech, Sicilian, the Moscow
variation
where my headphones turned off. Just a
second.    So let me remember
it's this
no, it's A six.
Bishop d three.     And is it
G five here? Let me check.   It's
not g. Five here.   Goddamn. There's a
line or black goes G five
here.
It's not here.
I'm trying to
remember. I swear. There is a line
where black goes G five. And it's very
similar to this.
So this
how does it
go   here?
Here?
No, it's c three.
Oh, I remembered. It's c
four. Yes. And
now 55 games that G five
is the most popular move in this
position. There we go. And
famously, uh, Alex, uh, Sasha
Grishuk was one of the first people to
play this. In 2015, Vessel
and de Paulov played this for the first time
ever against Magnus, and won
in the Singfield Cup to Paulo beat Carlson
with black in this line. Worth checking out.
If you're interested, just search up that
game.
Um, in any case, I'm, um,
digressing. Now, the engine
is no longer a fan of this, but
that's not the point, as you can understand.
Imagine facing this for the first time ever.
And in 2015, maybe engines were approving.
It, uh, the point of G five here is a little
bit different. You're trying to go G four,
but you're also trying to get White to
release the E five square. And,
of course, you're trying to open the G file
for attack    so you
can check out this game. But the bottom line
is that G five is it sounds
crazy, but it's a common idea in
many different types of openings. Of course,
in the French, this is also
ridiculously common
in many cases. In the Taraj
French, you get a situation
where basically     after nine
GF three, there is even the move G five
in this position. This exists.
And the idea is to push G four. Again, a
different reason. You're trying to weaken
White's control over D four. But, uh,
remember that if you see a move that sounds
that looks crazy, chances are
it's actually standard fare in a lot of
different positions. Also, you're sort
of preparing to fianceto the bishop. So it's
like an extended fianceto. Now,
the engine gives an edge for White after.
This. First of all, 92 is not
necessarily a human move. I would be more
inclined to play 91 to keep the darkskirt
Bishop open. But apparently, after H five
already, even objectively, black is better
because white is so cramped.  So
apparently 92 is the top engine movement.
Now we go h five. I would like
to have this with black. This looks
fun. Nobody's going to play f
three here. That's a weird McQueenie
one. What are these moves? I feel
like the human move here
is like night C four. And
immediately white is much worse. I
guess night C Four gets chased away, maybe
night B Three to open the Bishop.
Queen c seven. Typical
move in the Sicilian Con, getting
the queen in a nice square. And then Bishop
d six to aim at the h. Two pond.
So let's say Bishop B Three. Bishop d
six.   It's just a very
tactical position, a super risky
light, but something worth playing
if you're facing a lower rated opponent,
because this is how quickly it can get bad.
G three, H Four,
and already black is winning because you
have this sack on G three. It's not really a
sack. And black is a massive
attack.    F. Uh, g queen
g. Three is checkmate.  Okay,
so we just discovered is this a
novelty? Let's check.
Let's check if this is a novelty.
It is not. It's been played, and it's
been played by GM's. Sarik
played this in 2003.
Somebody played it, and it's Olivia Weisser,
uh, played. And guess what? I was right.
90, uh,   two, was played three
times,   but by correspondence
players, 91 is what the humans
played. So giovanovich
grandmaster.
Um okay. F three was played by
Baklan 2600.
Visor responded with Bishop
D Six, the game from 2003.
And
in this position, apparently, black is
supposed to drop the bishop back and pave
the way for D Five. But already black is
better.   In the other human
game, bishop E three was played
by a GM.  By
a GM. And after D Five,
apparently white, black is already much
better.   So what this tells you is
that the human value of this line is
incredibly high. Most humans, all of the
humans who have had this have
gotten terrible positions with white. Bishop
G seven.   Attacking. D
four. And if DC, then D Four forks the
bishop of the night. So, we have discovered
already a very interesting line. And so the
way to play this line, in conclusion, is to
start with A six. We examine Bishop C
Four.   Bishop d three is the main
line. Now we go e six. We
don't fear knight D Four, because here we
have this D five idea with queen
G Five against E five.
And if castles, we drop the knight back
to C six.        Uh,
bishop E two, we can repeat moves against
the higher rated opponent, or
we can play G Five with the idea of G four
and H five.   There's also the
move B Three here that I've played with
White, but B Three, as
far as I remember, you can just go G
Six and counteract White's Bishop
with your own bishop. Typical
developing. Now night a four. I've had this
against Min, actually, where we trade
bishops like this. And I'm pretty sure
Minn correctly plays d six.
Rookie One and E
Five just pushed upon through, grabbed the
center, and Black is a great position here.
Knight f Six Castle The D Five score is
weak, but it cannot really be occupied by a
piece.     So
wild complications. But
Black is totally comfortable here.
So Knight takes B Five by me, was actually
an inaccuracy. You can see stockfish
kind of goes up. It still
says it's equal, but
I already felt very risky.
Apparently, the correct move here no, sorry,
is E Six,
and apparently this version
is playable after
B five. Wow.
But this looks scary, doesn't it? I
mean, this looks even scarier than the game
continuation. Bishop g five with tempo.
Uh, now, it was
97 blocking the bishop. Yeah, this is
computer play.    So
at a grandmaster level, what you often do
and the misconception is that
GM's just plug positions into the
engine, and that's how you make a file.
No, see, it says equal.
But I would never, ever recommend
for anybody to go for this position with
Black in a game.   How do I know
that? Just intuitive feel. It looks
horrible. It just looks at
95. There might be some sacrifices
on D Five,    even though it gives
zeroes.    I mean, if
you actually just look at the line, f
Six is the only move nobody would ever
play that
because if you play Bishop B Seven, then
already it's plus minus. So you have to
decide when you're analyzing with an engine
also using your field, are you actually
comfortable playing the position? At the end
of the day, you have to be the
one   being comfortable with
the position. And if for whatever reason,
you don't feel comfortable, you feel like
you won't be able to handle the resulting
middle game in a game, then you
shouldn't play the line. You should search
until you find stuff that you actually feel
comfortable with. And that's what
we did here. So after D 64 and Queen
D Four, apparently Black is already
clearly worse, and it's due to this crazy
move queen B Four,
um,
Pakra asks, as a low rated
player, why does playing against Long Castle
like this feel scared? Well,   you see,
it's less that you're playing against Long
Castle and more that you're behind
massively in development. White has already
castled and gotten all of his
minor pieces out, and you've gotten no
minor pieces out. Black can't move
here. Right? You can't move this
bishop because you dropped G Seven. And
if you have to make a super weakening move
like F Six in order to
survive, well, that's a bad sign. That's a
sign that this position is super hard to
handle.
But isn't it equal?
It is, but only with insanely
precise engine moves that I wouldn't be
comfortable forcing myself to
find.
I hope this makes sense.
I'm trying to explain and give you
like a metastrategy for analyzing with an
engine since we're already on this kind of
general topic.
Um, so
anyways, d. So why
is queen B four such a strong
move? Well, it's because
of the ensuing idea of
putting the bishop on B six. This idea is
insanely strong. If
white goes anywhere except
before then black is fine. You can see
the engine gives even slight edge for black.
And h six is what I was planning to play.
And then, uh, knight F six. Now,
this is what I call the Smith's love idea.
If you play night f six immediately, this is
inaccurate because if bishop G
five takes F six and then Nt
five, this idea of removing a
defender and then
occupying the square with the knight
is most famously
illustrated    in a
game played in the 40s by
Vastly SMITHLove, the Soviet world
champion.   Now, um, this is a very
famous, um,   game that's been shown
way too many times. It's not the only
illustration  of this topic, and I've
shown this before in the speed run. But
hey, you got to look at stuff that
you already know. That's part of what
learning is all about.    So, Smith's
Love had this position
just a moment.
There we
go.   Stockfish, uh,   is off, which
is why you have this weird
panel.   What does Smithlov play in
this position? What's going on? Well, you
should see the similarity. There is a weak
square on D five, but that square
is defended by black's knight. So,
Smithlov goes bishop G five very
famously.   Then he
eliminates the night    and
then he positions his own knight on D
five.    Um, and
this actually uses some tactics to make it
work. If queen takes C two,
you might notice that there is
a forkable square on C seven,
right? So this is a trick
question. What is white's best move?
There is a mupois, the most popular wrong
answer. And the mupoa is very
instructive. And then there's the correct
move.   Let's see who can
avoid the trick.
So,    most of you are
like rooksty one. It's rooksty
one. But see, uh,
I call this queen disease.
When you don't
realize that you've given up 1000
pieces for your queen, it's
the same exact cons of your when you're
winning an exchange. Right? You have to
realize that an exchange is not that much
material. So what you're doing is you're
giving away      a, uh,
crap tone of ponds here on the queen site.
And what's their material count at the end?
Well, Black has three pawns for the
exchange.  This is not
impressive. But what you have to notice is
that black's queen basically has to keep in
contact   with the C seven
squared must stay on the C
file. So what move can we
start with to prevent queen
takes B two from being a thing? It's
rook f two. Excellent. Now, notice that
bishop H four, there's always the move G
three. I know some of you might be thinking,
oh, what about that move? No,
the queen has to move on the C
file.   Now, again, we
use the same principle. Rook C one, again,
is premature because if queen takes A two so
again, we play B three. We just keep
chasing the queen down the C file. And
only when we're ready do we play rook C one
and 90 C seven. Okay?
So
hopefully that made sense.
So this is the Smith love
idea.   Um,
this idea has been
applied
ad nauseam  in
a gazillion different types of
situations.
I've had it played against me many
times.     An, uh, example
I have shown before on stream,
um, is this
game against Kudrin. Kudrin being
a typical
Russian GM that I faced, uh,
quite a few times when I was, like,
22, 2300.
So Kudrin
had, um, this position against me. I was
black. Again, same opening
Nidorf, right? And this
structure very often occurs in the night or
so it's not a coincidence that
you actually get this often.
And of course, he goes bishop to G
five. Same drill,
eliminating the night   I took
on a two.    So
he just takes and goes back,
doesn't give a damn. And
eventually,   okay, here he makes
an amazing move. I love this
next move he plays. This is so freaking
instructive.  So what move do you want to
play but can't and why can't you play
it? Logical thinking is a great
exercise in logical thinking
and, like, actually
calculating. So you want to play 95,
right?  And by the way, a
rook on D five is still a sexy P. This is a
nice output, but you you don't want to give
up C two because the whole queen type
collapses. So you might say, okay, well,
let's defend the C two pawn. And I think
most of you are probably, let's go queen D
two. The problem with queen D
two is the black goes rook AC eight.
And again, you're in trouble because you
have to move. The night goes c two   So
Kujrin plays a classic grandmaster
move who can find it,
and there's two moves that do the same
thing, but he makes the more elegant move.
So most of you, if I read you
guys right, are thinking rook A, C
one. But he goes rook A
two.    And, well, what the
heck is the difference? Well, rook A C one
is inferior for a variety of reasons.
The rook on C one is
totally tied down to the pawn.
The rook on A two is
preparing in for the event that
white plays well. B five is played. Ah, a
five.   And the rook on a two
now defends the a five pawn and the
c two pawn. And later
on, further down the line, when
white moves the night away, maybe he
can push the pawn out of c two and then
double on the default. So the rook on a two
is just better placed. And finally he
achieves his aim. He gets
his rook to d five, and he proceeds to
outplay me. Now watch what he does.
Now, I
mentioned that the rook on d five
was a good piece, but what piece do you
really want to go to d five. Well, it's the
night. And watch what he does. Bang,    he
goes queen e four.
Bang,
c three. And look at this.
His rook on a two is actually
doing something. Now it's defending f two.
That was a very prophetic move.
You see many moves
later, it's actually come in handy,
the fact that he's put the rock on a two.
This is the elegance of positional play.
You do stuff     for the future.
Now you don't know if the future is ever
going to turn into reality, but one time out
of three it does.
And now 93 and 95,
and he has fully completed
positional domination, and
he proceeded to win the game. But all of
this stemmed from the Smith's love idea,
bishop g five.   Okay, so maybe I
belabored this, but
now you'll never forget it. Hopefully
now you'll
fully understand this concept of
eliminating a piece to access
the square.
Um, okay.
So back we go to the
game, and we're going to turn stockfish
on again,
just
because we've been analyzing on the engine,
and that's fine with me.
So instead, that's why we want to
go h six here. So that after
castle's nine f six, why can still
put the night on the but here
the worst piece to occupy an
outpost with is the queen.
Okay,
um, because why? Well, because the queen
is ridiculously vulnerable,
and we can chase the queen away first by
putting our queen on c seven. Not this,
because it blunders b seven.
But first Queen C. Seven. While
you're at it, you can hit the pawn. And then
bishop b six and bishop b seven are the
great position.    So
this would have been fine. Queen b four
is incredibly strong. Now, the engine gives
us some ways that we could survive this. I'm
not particularly interested because we've
already extracted the lessons from the
opening. Apparently, h six makes things even
worse. And after night f six, it's
officially a losing position. It's already
plus two.   Apparently the
only move here was in fact, to play queen e
seven castles and somehow
to   just, um,   pretend that nothing's the
matter. But this position sucks. Now, of
course, what I had missed from a distance,
I thought that I would go here
and notice that if white doesn't have
night takes e five, black is fine,
but white has this incredibly annoying move.
95 and this is crushing because the queen
is trapped. The queen is literally
trapped. You have to take and then you get
checkmated.
Um,     well, the Jospin
game is a title Tuesday game, so it's not
that interesting.
Um, and the
crazy thing is that if you develop and you
say, I have an idea. Well, now
knight takes C five is not possible because
after de,   we're attacking the
queen simultaneous, we're going to win a
piece. Well, you have to keep calculating.
It is possible because after rook D seven
before, there is the check on D eight
anyway, and White wins H eight
and white's up in exchange and winning the
game. So all of these tactical lines
work perfectly in White's favor. We had to
move our queen again. And bishop C seven is
a sexy move, just attacking
from behind. And Black's
position simply collapses. Maybe king D
seven could have been tried. But here there
are more tactics with rook takes D six and
rook D one picking up the queen with a
devastating attack.    And,
um, there's just nothing that can be
done here. The position collapses
and nothing's developed. And
White is just taking everything. And Check
mating me down the D file and the rest,
of course,    we've, uh,
analyzed. We're not going to look at the
endgame in this video. We've already gone
quite a while. Uh, of course, White is
totally winning. I could talk about
more accurate, less accurate moves, but at
the end of the day, our opponent
played very well up until
Blundering. Uh,   that fork. So   I think
this is we're going to pause guys, I'm not
sure how long this video is going to last,
but quite an eventful speedrun
game.    Wasn't, uh,
expecting something this crazy. But
again, our focus in the speedrun is
on opening. So I hope that you enjoyed the
discussion of NC six,
bishop B five, and now you know how to play
against it.  Uh,   now you know
how to play against knight F three. There is
also bishop C four, which is the
old main line. And I'm
quite sure that we're going to face this
line at least one more time. So we're going
to get a chance to discuss this theory
later. But hope you enjoyed the game. This
is a slightly different method of analysis.
We had the engine on and I
know some people are going to be like
having the engine on,
but hopefully you can
appreciate that we were focusing
on openings here
and obviously we were checking our
opponent's place. So hope you can
forgive this deviation from the norm.
Um, and on that note,
folks, it's almost 5 hours. I'm going to
call it a night. I will see you
all tomorrow.   And I
am going to raid.
Who am I going to raid? I'm going to
raid. Fiona. Fiona
covering the European rapid championship.
Thank you all for hanging out. Thanks for
the support. Once again, I have a YouTube
channel. If you subscribe, you help me
tremendously. Thank you, everybody, and
goodbye.